Bonjour, nous avons reçu beaucoup
de questionslors de notre journée
spéciale impôts le 31 mars. Voici
quelques-unes de ces questions
et les réponses fournies par les experts de
la maîtrise en fiscalité de
l'Université de Sherbrooke.
Première question : «Pourun étudiant
qui étudie dans une autre région
que celle où se trouve son adresse principale,
est-ce qu'il a d'autres frais déductibles,
à partles frais scolarité?»
Réponse : il y a un crédit d'impôt pour
frais de scolarité, Canada et Québec. Il n'existe
pas de mesures spécifiques pour un étudiant qui
étudie dans une autre région que son domicile.
Mais si l'étudiant doit déménager pour étudier
et que ce déménagement le rapproche d'au moins
40 km de son nouveau lieu d'études, il pourrait,
à certaines conditions, être admissible à la
déduction pour frais de déménagement. Il y
a d'autres mesures possibles sur des frais
d'intérêts à payer sur un prêt étudiant ou
encore pour les nouveaux diplômés qui travaille
dans une région ressource éloignés. Deuxième
question : «Comment déclarer des transactions
en cryptomonnaie?» Réponse : comme n'importe
quelle autre transaction. Si vous gagnez un
revenu ou avez réalisé des gains payer avec
la cryptomonnaie, vous devrez les ajouter
à votre déclaration de revenus lorsque vous
effectuez une conversion de cryptomonnaie en
monnaie courante. Vous pourriez réaliser un
gain ou une perte en capital. Advenant un gain,
la moitié de celui-ci sera imposable sous forme
de gains en capital et la moitié de la perte en
capital sera déductible s'il y a lieu.
Troisième question : «Des collègues ont reçu
un avis de remboursement de 2000 $ de PCU
versée en trop. Ce montant faisait
partie de nos revenus en2020.
Comment allons-nous récupérer l'impôt
payé sur ce revenu?»
Réponse : vous allez recevoirun feuillet le T4A et un feuillet RL1 pour les résidents du Québec,
où le montant de votre
remboursement sera indiqué.
Ce feuillet vous permettra de récupérer votre impôt payé en 2020 endéduisant le montant
de remboursement lors de la production de votre déclaration de revenus.
Vous pouvez demander la déduction sur 2020,
et donc corriger vos déclarations passées.
Ou vous pouvez également demander
la déduction sur votre déclaration 2022.
Quatrième question : «Peut-on réduire le coût
pour faire un rapport d'impôt
comme le prix du logiciel
de TurboImpôt?»
Réponse : si vous êtes un salarié, vous ne pouvez pas déduire le coût afin de produire
votredéclaration de revenus
parce qu'il s'agit d'une dépense personnelle.
Si vous êtes un travailleurautonome ou si vous possédez un immeuble locatif
pour lequel vous avez gagné du revenu de location,
il vous sera possible de déduire le coût
en fonction d'un pourcentage
des revenus.
Cinquièmequestion : «Allons-nous bénéficier cette annéed'un report pour payer un solde dû? »
Réponse: cette année, la date limite pour produire
les déclarations de revenus et le 2 mai 2022.
Lesdélais ne sont pas reportés et les gouvernementsn'ont fait aucune annonce à ce sujet.
Plus deréponses encore sur
Radio-Canada.ca/impots2022